[Applause]
whenever you talk about doing Twisted
Metal everyone's excited about seeing
the vehicles
to take a vehicle from its concept to
reality the first thing that we have to
do is read the scripts and we tease out
of the scripts the things that help
build the character because in Twisted
Metal the cars are every bit as much of
the character as the people the actors
from there we start to do our research
look and see what vehicles are in the
game itself kind of how they look and
then we pitch some ideas we were a
little bit like magpies we took bits and
pieces that appeal to us from all the
games we didn't like say oh we're going
to copy this or oh we're going to copy
that mainly we work with the art
Department in Victoria Paul because
ultimately she's designing the entire
production the cool thing was she also
allowed us some flexibility to make
suggestions on things design wise to
make sure that it would practically work
with what we were doing in film
here for the show I'm definitely here
for the show
we start with cardboard and mocking up
basic designs to see how it'll work and
then start practically building it
sometimes we have to remove fenders or
doors and sometimes we're building
fabricating from scratch we bought some
baking sheets you would bake cookies on
and use that on the roof because that
was what was easy for us to do and work
and it looked great and unless I told
you it was a baking sheet you would
never know that that was a baking sheet
how about a little kill music
we're putting the things together we
have to figure out practically in
conjunction with visual effects who then
takes it the next step to make the
vehicles do some of the things like
shoot missiles out of sweet tooth's eyes
we have to figure out a way to build all
these crazy things on a car but still
make sure the car can perform doing
stunt work the first thing that we had
to do is make sure we installed some
stunt bricks that allowed them to lock
up the rear brakes and spin the vehicles
around
we have to set the vehicle up with
special fuel tanks so that they have a
very low amount of fuel in the vehicles
if it's to flip over from there it goes
to the guns each gun had to be selected
and then we had to modify each gun to
make sure it announced it and made sense
for each vehicle
it'd be great if you could warn me
before you drift like that I've slammed
my head into the window I said hang on
after that it basically goes to paint
and aging so that uh it can look like
it's been sitting out for the last 20
years post-apocalypse
do them all in terms of its cars and
what we are asking of the cars
with the hero card that Evelyn that
played throughout the most of the the
season we actually had four vehicles we
had a hero we had a stunt vehicle we had
a backup stunt vehicle and we had a
remote drive vehicle or a pod vehicle
where we have a device on top of the car
where a Stunt Driver can control the
vehicle and drive it around while the
actors are free to do their roles
without having to operate the vehicle
to drive the vehicle is pretty darn cool
and we get the opportunity to warm them
up peeling Donuts in the parking lot
using his stunt brakes all of the
vehicles are tons of fun to just drive
around have fun with